I've thought about killing you more
times than I can count
do it Game of Thrones it is all coming
to an end how do you feel about the way
that it ends there are no better writers
in television than Dan Weiss and David
Benioff they ended it brilliantly better
than I could have imagined and you
people are in for it what about the way
it ends for your character specifically
it ends beautifully for my character
whether it be tragic or not your
reaction when you first read it Game of
Thrones may be ending but clearly the
cast bond is still tight Peter
Dinklage's co-star Emilia Clarke showed
support by stepping out for the LA
premiere of his latest HBO project my
dinner with Irv a right away because of
his personal Daenerys Peters new film is
based on a true story centered around
the life of French actor Herve
Villechaize tell me what it felt like to
be famous
[Music]
sacha gervasi the writer director
approached me about 14 years ago with a
very was a short film version of the
film that we made eventually made it
hooked me because of Sasha's personal
connection to it because he interviewed
Herve before he died and got to know the
man very intimately as a journalist in a
very short amount of time which has it's
sort of sort of strange surreal quality
to it all and then you end up really
transforming for the part the accent and
what was that like for you to transform
into him well I'll never transform into
him but I just did my version of what I
thought I could do liz Himelstein really
helped me along the way and of course
sasha was invaluable well and he really
went through this TV show that
catapulted him to a whole other level of
stardom you
I've had a similar experience how do you
think Fame has affected you well Fame is
what we sort of try and tackle in the
film it's an abstract idea that really
has very little to do with you at the
end of the day it comes from a lot of
hard work but oftentimes it's sort of a
goal rather than a residual of hard work
you know kids are asked the number one
thing when kids are asked where do they
want to be when they grow up lately is
they want to say that I want to be
famous and you say where they don't
really have a comprehension of what it
means to be that they just want to be
famous and we sort of addressed that in
the movie
[Music]